when bruce springsteen and you were on
stage together doing an ac dc song i
don't know where you were couple times
in australia yeah yeah
is that the biggest rush in the world
for you i mean is that part of the great
thing about being a famous rock star
i was touring solo and he was with the e
street band
and that was one night where we had a
night off so we get into town and then
we
run over to the show and bruce is
already the show's supposed to start at
eight it's like ten
after and and john lando says you know
hey bruce wants to see you
and i was like oh no i'm good i'm good
he says no he wants to see you i said
now i'd rather not bother him before the
show he says
no i think he's yeah i'd be the same way
he's like uh
he had died you know i got an idea
and he said here's the deal
all right first song acdc
highway to hell and you take a verse
all right take a verse and then you're
done you could drink beer you can do
whatever you want none of this encore
[ __ ] you don't have to wait around
first song hit it with me and you're
good to go
so that's that's how it went you know
the best part of when you get to do that
isn't actually playing it in front of
people the best part
is when you're right across the small
table or whatever you're sitting on the
same couch
playing the song and hearing them saying
you know that's playing in front of
people that's like the price of
admission but
but that moment of just hearing the guy
right in front of you and and connecting
and learning chords and
that's something is it weird when you go
out with like like when neil young
and you are performing together or
something like to me neil young is god
you know i know he's been big in your
life
well he took our whole band under his
wing
everything he taught us at the time
resonated
and it came at a time when we needed to
be taught we needed
a north star i do remember one at one
time we were at the
the the ranch and and uh at his place
and we took a walk and
it's kind of that their famous fence
line i think uh everybody knows this is
nowhere or something
right smoking a joint and then we sat
down near this kind of little pond and
he said hey
just you know there might be some people
that that
that'll try to pull you away from this
group you know but but you guys
you know your the sum is greater than
the parts you know remember that and
the whole thing and i he said i'm sure
that's probably already happened to you
and and and i thought no i'm i'm good
with these guys and and
actually no no one's
yeah but i like the advices coming from
the guy who left crosby stills and yeah
you know
looking back on that story you know i
realized that a few years later
you